[Music]
so when going over the list for this
year's Disney semver I knew I had to
drop one of these two movies to make
room smart house or princess protection
I asked people on my facebook who grew
up with these movies which one they
wanted to see thinking they would say
princess protection because hey it's
Disney and princesses that's just kind
of their thing but overwhelmingly
everyone said smart house not just
picking that one but praising that one
like it was actually a legitimately good
film so I popped it in take a look and
yeah it actually kind of is I mean okay
it's corny has bad effects as clearly
aiming for kids but I found myself
legitimately entertained by what was
going on and even laughing quite a bit
the story centers around a family who
big Shaq just lost their mother recently
the son has put it upon himself to take
care of the household and is decided to
enter a contest to win a smart house a
home where everything is taken care of
by computer they of course win and find
that the house is actually quite perfect
apart from a glitch here there it
actually seems to do everything for him
and seems quite pleasant but when those
glitches do happen they have to call the
inventor who it turns out is sparking a
bit of a romance with the dad the son
doesn't like this as he's still getting
over the loss of his mother so he
decides to program into the computer
named Pat but she should be more
motherly hoping the father won't see the
necessity of dating the computer not
only complies but over time it gets
obsessive it looks up all the motherly
things that mothers are supposed to do
in dozen times 10 she's strict but also
playful it forces good morals but
doesn't always practice them when
looking after her kids and yeah starts
to see the family as her family when
everybody realizes pet might be going
too far she suddenly turns herself into
human form a hologram projection that
decides is too dangerous outside and so
she decides to hold the family hostage
it's as crazy as it sounds but in all
the best ways the writing in this movie
at least when it comes to the dialogue
it's not necessarily the best but they
got good actors and a good director to
really bring it to life they can make
unfunny lines seemed legitimately
humorous and take non emotional scenes
and make them actually kind of
tearjerkers the family is not a rotten
family they don't just throw insults to
each other all the time like on a sitcom
they actually get along pretty well
and they're likable and they have
distinct identities and again I think a
lot of that comes from the acting and
the directing the son for example in any
other movie would be seen as unrealistic
or strange why he be obsessing over
keeping the house clean and tidy and
such but the movie and the performances
do a great job showing that it really is
because he can't fill the void of his
missing mother he sees that when his
father wants to date somebody else its
betraying his mother that's some heavy
material for a Disney film to take on
but by god they take it on and they do
it seriously it isn't just the full
house routine where you know oh this is
where you hear the serious moment and
you tune out and they just say those
catchphrases no they really talk about
it and you really listen speak in a full
house all of these characters and jokes
could so easily fall into that category
being too corny and too nice but there
is enough conflict in their everyday
lives and of course with the computer
and the missing mother so it never
really feels ungenerous katey sagal as
path is a perfect choice every time she
talks it's funny it's a great evolution
going from that robotic voice that could
be hilariously obnoxious not to worry
Nick my database was prepared by a team
of nutritionists to a gradually changing
tone of her being this overly obsessed
even insane mother does it hurt like the
dickens baby nobody goes after my boy
and gets away unpunished and when she
finally takes on human form it's even
better look at that evil smile that's
both funny and terrifying it's
interesting that this movie was directed
by levar burton Geordi from Star Trek
this honestly makes too much sense now
he did he act on Star Trek but he
directed several episodes and if you
watch Star Trek you know that lathis
centers around sci-fi technology which
often ties into the problems and
conflicts that are happening on the ship
say a family coming to grips with the
loss of a family member while the
technology in their lives has created a
conflict that ties into that struggle
this guy has had years of watching and
directing stories like this and he does
it wonderfully here the only problems I
really have our nitpicks like there's a
scene where Pat wants to torment a bully
in my opinion it could have been a lot
meaner and a lot funnier there's also a
scene where Peck is a loving look to the
boy at the end even though it's clearly
the same look that was done before and
was meant to be evil that time little
things like that can kind of get in the
way along with some of the corny effects
but honestly the story the characters
and the acting really pull it through I
feel like everything that can and should
be done with a kids film about a smart
house is done in smart house it's a
movie kids can watch for the zany news
but adults can also get a few laughs and
even some dramatic moments out of it to
not hate your ones but just don't well
enough the best way to put it smart
house is a smart flick
you